[Applause]
little while ago we tallied up the five
best libertarian TV shows ever now it's
time to look at the five TV shows that
are the absolute worst from a
libertarian perspective
to be fair just about everyone hates
this sanctimonious drama created by
Aaron Sorkin the newsroom follows the
on-air Tantrums of will McAvoy a
preening self-righteous anchor man who
can't open his mouth without inveighing
against capitalism gun rights or
political speech with which he doesn't
agree
it's like Ron Burgundy but
unintentionally funny they can call
themselves the Tea Party they can call
themselves conservatives but we should
call them what they are the American
Taliban they viewing only a couple of
months after the 9/11 attacks in 2001 24
exists as nothing less than agitprop for
the national security state and the
righteous evisceration of civil
liberties super agent Jack Bauer is
constantly thwarting presidential
assassinations dirty bomb detonations
and drug cartel monsters through a mix
of state sanctioned torture black-bag
jobs and good old-fashioned abrogation
of the Constitution Jack there's
something called due process it's why
we've got judges and juries and laws
should dear to me about the law
[Music]
this show suckled Millennials on the
teat of dramatically defective
environmentalism in the early 1990s the
spirit of the planet Gaia sends five
rings - kids located all around the
globe that give rise to the
super-powered Captain Planet
remember kids capitalism is evil and
destructive unless you're creating
preachy cartoons for Ted Turner's TBS
these new trick Nets sure people
fashionably efficient just like refining
the ocean will be a living thing left
was our crew and every pitcher knows
that there's plenty of five-buck
[Music]
the National Football League isn't just
the wealthiest sports league on the
planet it's the most morally bankrupt
forget about ongoing controversies over
the league's domestic violence policies
and the Redskins name the NFL is the
ultimate poster child for corporate
welfare state sanctioned Kartal is a
ssin and government granted privilege
sure the games themselves are must-see
TV but the political economy of the
league which is organized as a
non-profit due to a special act of
Congress stinks worse than the 1976
Tampa Bay Buccaneers ever did we have
seen all too much of the NFL doing wrong
the original series takes place in a
future where humanity has finally
transcended all forms of warfare cash
transactions and shirts with collars the
Starship Enterprise has adventures
throughout the galaxy are supposedly
guided by the Federation's
prime directive which forbids humans
from intervening in the domestic affairs
of the planets they visit and yet when
he's not engaging in zero-gravity sex
with an endless procession of comely
space aliens captain james t kirk is
mucking around with every civilization
from here to the Romulan neutral zone
like LBJ on viagra these words and the
words that follow they must apply to
everyone or they mean nothing do you
understand
I do not fully understand well what do
you think of our pets what'd we get
right and what did we blow completely
set your phasers to stun and let us know
in the comments for reason TV I'm Nicola
[Applause]